Will you guys hit some headlines with us?
Let's do it.
Oh my god.
All right.
Why not?
Okay.
Rossy!
All right, I'll hit it.
Okay, first up, well, you know, when it comes to dating
things are looking up for the little guys.
The "New York Post" reports short men
are having a renaissance.
In fact, TikTok says that we're smack in the middle
of something called Short King Spring, mhmm.
So if you're a cutie below 5'8",
I'm talking to you, uh-huh.
Wait, is he talking to us?
Yeah, Short King Spring could turn into Short King Summer.
And, look, people are checking out hot guys
like Tom Holland and Zendaya.
Look at them, she's taller than him.
Gorgeous.
Mhmm.
Joe Jonas and Sophie Turner.
Cute.
Yep, yep, yep.
Listen, I'm all for Short King Spring.
I was pushing Pee-Wee Winter for a while,
it never caught on.
But to be under 5'8",
I'm 5'7", I'm getting close,
but I'm glad the tide is turning.
And there's a lot of misreporting
on the height of actors.
I mean, I don't wanna give anything away,
but it's an illusion, film.
Chris Hemsworth 5'6", honest to God.
Bradley Cooper, Bradley Cooper 5'2".
Channing Tatum, 4'11", you heard it hear.
Tom Cruise is 5'1".
You guys did your research.
Yeah.
Yes.
That's right.
And tall beautiful people
can sometimes not be too swift on the uptake,
not real bright.
David and I are the exception.
But my point is this, no, go ahead.
Drew, short shaming has gotta go away,
because you can't help it.
They say fat shaming is bad,
and maybe you could have something to do with that.
Short, you're just short.
If I could eat a lot and be taller, I would.
So it's not gonna happen.
Well, also I'm sure
it's probably to deceptive for a lot of people.
What do you mean?
Just saying.
Understood.
What are you talking about?
I don't know, I'm just saying.
Oh, you mean nature has a way of balancing gifts out?
Yeah.
Yeah, Drew.
I see.
Our mind is in the gutter.
Yes, she is, Church Lady, yes, she is!
I'm a bad girl!
All right.
You are.
And I wanna spank you!
Like I need a good spanking!
Next up.
All right, next story.
All right, we've got a dilemma that we found on Reddit.
I thought this was actually really interesting.
This was discussed on "Elvis Duran's Morning Show,"
who I love.
Hey, Elvis, if you're out there.
What do you do if your sister is planning to name
your future nephew, their child, after an actual crime?
One woman wrote that she's feuding with her sister
after criticizing her name choice of Arson.
Which is a rip off of "Firestarter."
"Firestarter," yeah, hello.
I know my son's name was Poison Pete,
but that's a whole other story.
My kid, Harper, goes to school,
but the real names are like Yale, Captain,
like real interesting names that I never had.
So those are kind of just cool and different.
But when it gets into crimes,
I don't love it as much, maybe no in school.
I mean, I had a switch hitter name
that always traumatized me, Dana.
I got put in girl's P.E., not a joke, in high school.
Names are funny, David has a regular name,
I've got kind of a switch hitter name,
and Drew is a switch hitter name.
I was gonna say I have a boy/girl name.
I'm into the androgynousness, so you know.
I just think there should be a rule.
Just because it's a pretty word,
doesn't make it a good name.
Like you don't wanna be,
"Hey, Grand Larceny, come home."
Exactly.
'Cause you know what else is a pretty word?
Hey, Car Crash.
Yeah.
You know what else is a pretty word?
Chlamydia is a pretty word.
Beautiful word.
But not a great name.
And not a great thing.
No.
Gonorrhea, eat your cereal.
Napalm, stop!
I like Captain, David.
That's a good name.
It is kind of a cool one.
Yeah, it's hard to argue.
That's kind of hip.
I like these,
but there's some interesting names.
Kayak.
Captain.
Mhmm, well, I'm the captain now
'cause I have the next story.
All right.
Yay, Captain Rossy!
And in another conundrum,
"InStyle" has an advice column
and a woman wrote in to say it bothers her
that her boyfriend likes bikini photos
of other women on Instagram.
Not famous bikini models,
but just everyday women who are posing in bikinis online
that he actually knows.
He's liking their photos.
So here's the question.
Oh, he knows?
Even worse, yeah.
Right?
Yeah, I mean.
Is it okay?
I'll take this first, Dana.
I think if you have a girlfriend or wife, it is rude,
and those likes are to get attention.
It's like Morse code, like, like, like, like,
like, like, like, like, like,
that you're just trying to communicate
and you want them to maybe notice you.
And that's a tough one to defend I would say.
(upbeat music)